[Music]
my name is debo Adair big bay I'm a
product manager here at Google cloud and
I'm joined by my colleague Stephen
Elliott also a product manager here at
Google cloud and we focus on creating
value for you guys the customers and
partners by focusing specifically on the
billing product area now I know we're
gonna go over a lot in our session today
and don't fret if you miss anything
there's gonna be a recording available
on YouTube after the conference is over
but more specifically today we want to
focus on helping you make your dollar go
further with DCP now in order to do that
we're gonna go over four main areas
today the first is an introduction the
what the why the how of using GCP we're
then going to move into how you can
drive value using GCP products then
we'll focus on what cost management
tools you can use in order to ensure
that you're driving that value but also
saving your costs and then finally we'll
wrap up and review so without further
adieu let's go into our introduction now
there's the obvious question we have to
answer first why are businesses moving
to Google cloud it's a great question
when most companies are transitioning
into cloud the first thing they're often
looking to do is to reduce their costs
but that's not all from developers and
DevOps to sea level and board level
initiatives companies are looking to
take advantage of not just reducing
costs but increasing efficiency
increasing reliability and making sure
they have great security essentially
Google helps you better engage with your
customers it also helps you better
engage with your partners and it helps
you increase the productivity of your
employees by making sure both your needs
are met and you have room for further
innovation now I'm sure you've heard the
phrase a picture is worth
some words so indulge me for a moment
and a mental picture by means of an
analogy pizza
who doesn't love pizza now I'm going to
go off-script a little bit and say pizza
is like one of the best meals ever so
bonus tip you can have pizza for any
meal but just going back to the point
there are two different ways you can
think about pizza for the means of this
analogy the first is on premises pizza
that's the piece of a you make and then
there is Google Cloud Pizza that's the
pizza that we make as you can see
there's a number of different tasks
associated with making on premises pizza
and each of those tasks including
spending the time to go get the
ingredients spending the gas spending
the money and of course the thing you
can never get back time are actually
pretty high when it comes to making that
on-prem pizza yourself but when you go
with Google Cloud Pizza it's really
simple and fairly elegant you go online
you order the pizza you wait and you
enjoy that tasty goodness when you're
going to make the analogy between pizza
and being on premises it's really
similar to how you deal with your IT
infrastructure what you focus on is
dealing with all the varieties on
premises of tasks that you need to do
and we focus on our side of extracting
all the management that you have to do
or those tasks and doing it for you so
really when it comes down to it we're
making sure that you get the most value
out of it on top of that we help you
answer questions that are fairly
difficult to answer on your own on
premises like what if I want a specialty
pizza all the meats all the veggies what
if I want to make hundreds of pizzas and
deliver them to my customers we help you
scale so that brings us to the main
context of our talk today which is
thinking about the base equation of
where I get my net value from the big
idea that most companies typically think
about is that lift and shift means
extracting the value from moving to
cloud by just thinking about reducing my
total costs and then seeing that as a
total net value now that's true reducing
your total costs is a great thing
but the fact of the matter is it's not
an adequate way to think about the big
picture the truth about cloud is that
lifting and shifting your workloads is
not really the entire picture and does
not transform your IT by itself instead
you should really think about bridging
the gaps in between your current
business processes and the modernization
and the innovation you can achieve by
moving to cloud the more and more you
use GCPs technologies the more and more
you're able to accelerate the amount of
value you capture from moving to cloud
so I like to think about this as kind of
an iceberg picture in this and since
there's the obvious costs which are
using your compute using your other
resources on the cloud well there's the
less obvious costs like all it takes to
maintain that infrastructure on-premises
and then there's the value that you get
from abstracting away your concerns
about all the cloud work you do on
premises to the cloud and then there's a
less obvious value get such as
efficiencies productivity reliability
security so let's alter this equation
just a little bit to make sure that we
get the full value of moving to cloud
really the change in net value that you
can enjoy when you move to cloud is
really the total value of being in the
cloud itself all the things I just
mentioned and then you subtract from
that the total costs now for all of you
guys who are saying Deebo it's way too
early for me to be doing a math this
morning let's simplify it just think
about your total value and just think
about your total costs this has worked
fantastically for our friends over at
vendetta they focused on doing just that
getting their value out of a lot of GCP
products and then analyzing that value
using bigquery and a number of cost
management tools they've been able to
grow their business by 32% while keeping
their costs relatively flat I imagine a
lot of you could do the same thing by
using Google cloud so let's stop talking
about this in an abstract way unless
talk about it in a little bit more
concrete way let's focus on GCE or
Google compute engine as one of the
first products we can show you how to
drive more value the typical costs of
compute ownership are spread a loss a
number of elements one of them is the
building you got to pay the rent you got
to cover the electricity the lighting
the a/c and the security you've got to
think about the software operating
systems management utilities software
licenses you've also got to think about
people all the specialists the
consultants your employees and HR oh
yeah there's one more thing we forgot
the hardware you've got to make sure
that your compute is taken care of on
premises so you can actually run the
workloads you care about so there's not
just that that you have to think about
as well you also got to think about how
you actually drive the value of your
business let's start with the hardware
costs every 18 months or so your
Hardware more or less becomes
out-of-date and to keep that up to date
has a cost associated with it if you
want to make sure that you remain
competitive with those in your industry
you also want to take advantage of all
kinds of innovations that are fairly
expensive to come up with your own
on-prem such as GPUs TP use artificial
intelligence and machine learning you
also want to think about how you might
serve a new region of the world let's
say if you want to globally expand or
let's say that your business is doing
fantastic and you want to make sure you
can scale very quickly especially if
it's not expected and so that's where we
enter Google compute engine the
simplicity and elegance of it is its
core value you start the virtual
machines that you need for your
workloads when you need them you resize
them and scale as necessary and then you
shut down that VM when you're not using
it anymore the key to that is you pay
only for what you need well you guys
didn't come for the base explanation of
what a virtual machine is or how to use
it so you really came for finding out
how you can drive even more
value out of using GCE and other
products and that's very simple I like
to spread it into two elements behaviors
and tools on the behavior side you
definitely want to analyze and plan your
workloads think about seasonality think
about the duration think about the value
of your workloads are they
mission-critical figure out how you want
to segment those and use the right
machines for them the second thing I
tell you to do is think about virtual
machine types or families now we offer a
number of different ones of course
there's general-purpose VMs but there's
also different optimized VM families
that you should take advantage of for
example compute optimized VMs if you
want to think about performance or
memory optimized VMs if your storage is
very important to you or platform
optimized VMs if you're thinking about
specific types of operating systems or
platforms that you want your virtual
machines to run on then of course the
third behavior you really want to focus
in is resize the VMS as necessary think
about VMs being built of core and RAM
and sometimes additional attributes like
a - persistent disk or other things like
that make sure that you're using the
right size for what you need when we
move over to the tools part of what
you're going to do with your VMs you
want to make sure to take advantage of
the stack driver API now the stack
driver API is fantastic because it's
really giving you logging monitoring and
alerting right at your fingertips
programmatically on top of that we give
you what we like to call right sizing
recommendations right sizing
recommendations allow you to have the
proper size of VM after we've watched
you use those VMs for a given period of
time in order for you to save money or
be efficient and the way you use them
and finally there's a number of other
tools that we'd like for you to use such
as V pcs or Sol tenancy which means just
having your workloads alone on a VM
access control snapshotting of disk
images to make sure that you can get
quickly running with your VM and other
types of tools like that now I told you
in that equation earlier that I
mentioned it's not just about value it's
about
decreasing costs as well so let's take a
look at a few of the ways you can do
that we have custom machine types one of
the things that's interesting about all
those predetermined machine types that I
just mentioned in the previous slide is
that they tend to follow a specific
ratio of cords RAM if you need to you
can break that ratio and have a custom
machine type that's flexible and well
priced if you want to have a workload
that can withstand some interruption
let's say once every 24 hours you might
want to think about using preemptable
VMs preemptive VMs might get preempted
as their name suggests and they're
cheaper you can also use sustained use
discounts now this is a great thing that
you get automatically for long-running
workloads when your workloads gonna run
on a specific type of family the longer
and longer you use it the more effective
discounting you get and finally there's
committed use discounts when you commit
to using a certain amount of core and
RAM per month on a one or three-year
basis we're able to effectively scale
and plan capacity for you that planning
equals savings on our part and we're
more than happy to share the discount
with you now I've talked a little bit
more specifically about GCE but there's
a number of different benefits you can
joy across all GCP products and that
includes but it's not limited to the
fact that we have planetary scale and
networking these are not just the
services we're using to help you but
they're also the same types of services
we use to run many of our most famous
products like YouTube Gmail and G suite
we also have site reliability and
support think about them as very very
intelligent babysitters for your
workloads making sure that your precious
workloads don't do anything weird while
you need them to run we're backed by
Google security which of course I don't
need to tell you how important it is to
be secure when you're running your
workloads and we've got GCP wide tooling
logging and api's to connect you to all
the resources that you need so let's
kind of move forward in the compute
spectrum where my partner Steven is
going to
talk to you a little bit about all the
value can extract from products in the
compute spectrum in terms of different
ways to manage them all right thanks
Devo so I'll spend a little time talking
about managed compute and this is where
we move from being able to provision
virtual machines to actually managing
the infrastructure in operations for you
so you don't have to just to get a sense
of where we are in the room can I get a
show of hands if you feel comfortable of
course you know you don't have to but if
you think your teams and your software
application teams spend at least 25% of
the time maintaining the operations or
the infrastructure I thinks that's true
at least 25% how about at least 50% so
just kind of in the theme of this talk
which is to think about both cost and
value let's think about what would
happen if you could reduce the amount of
time the team spends on managing
infrastructure magazine operations
maintaining the applications doing
version management if you could reduce
that by half or three-quarters or in
some cases just fully reduce it and
really just focus on writing the code
and there's a couple of sessions in this
talk where will be talked about managed
services and that's really the game
we're trying to play which is help you
focus on the application you're building
so Deebo talked about compute engine and
that's on the left side of this screen
which is something that gives you full
control over the servers that you're
provisioning and then at the other end
of the spectrum is cloud functions where
you just write the code and that
function runs in the cloud automatically
provisioned automatically scaling with
events that trigger them and then in
between you get we still give you choice
for how much you want Google to manage
for you so let's talk a little bit about
those what what really is the choice and
I think it's a choice of what you feel
comfortable managing so in some cases
people love scheduling and people love
looking at logs and doing the monitoring
and having full control but they're
either applications that don't need that
level of control or the team just
doesn't that's not their expertise
that's not what they want to do so the
more and more we can manage for you the
more we believe you can focus on doing
what's really important in the cloud so
how do we do this so there's one word
that really catches how we do this
Plastics we just do it with plastics or
sorry containers containers are the way
to think about this is in the legacy
world in bare-metal servers you're
managing everything you're managing the
hardware the racks the operating systems
you're updating those the library is
making sure they're consistent across
deployments but what if we could manage
the hardware for you great so now you
are able to rent servers we can
virtualize that to make that more
efficient and rent servers through
something like compute engine but what
if we could manage that even further and
say well don't worry about the operating
system don't worry about other security
updates or library updates just deliver
that kind of a hermetically-sealed piece
of code that contains all the library
dependencies all the code that you want
to run that's a container and they don't
interfere with each other and so what
you deploy is what runs and then if we
can manage that even further and say you
know what don't even don't even think
about the library just right right the
Python write the code write the
JavaScript that you want to run and if
it's a common version or flavor of it
it'll run perfectly we have a lot of
experience doing this so Google was one
of the pioneers in container computing
and Linux and we've been doing this for
over ten years and one of the important
things I'm not going to read all the
benefits of being able to compute this
way but as you can abstract a lot of the
dependencies out of your application you
get all these benefits whether it's
portability speed the velocity of your
team security the dev team knowing that
what the what gets shipped to production
is going to run the way they tested it
and just simple scalability so one thing
we like to talk about at Google is
sublinear scaling so I don't know if
you've heard this term but it's the idea
that as your business grows and as your
application grows your team doesn't need
to scale in proportion with the success
of your business certainly wouldn't want
the other way around which is every new
user requires even more resources to
support so to give you a sense of how
this works over the last ten years I'm
using containers behind the scenes we
launched about four billion of them a
week our ops fleet has grown ten times
faster than the ops team and that's
really great sublinear you know order of
magnitude sub linear scaling that we can
achieve with this technology so where
does this appear in manage compute well
the first one I mentioned on the left
left hand
spectrum is google kubernetes engines so
what this really is if you're familiar
with kubernetes it's a way to manage a
container cluster on VMs and you could
either run this it's open source it's
one of the most popular github
repositories that has a lot of activity
and kind of mind shift from the
developer ecosystem
you know either run it yourself or you
can use GK to let J run it for you
manage the cluster for you update it do
all the security updates and then
because open source and portable you can
still interact with the cluster master
through cube control or cube cuddle some
people call it directly so the
management can be invisible to you
because you're still interacting with
the cluster the way you're used to if
you'd like more management of your
applications and you really don't want
to deal with deploying applications into
a cluster you might choose something
like Google App Engine so I mention this
is kind of in the middle of the spectrum
here you can focus on writing code in
common languages that might represent
the big app engine front-end app icon or
the big app engine back-end app icon
here and call other services as needed
to do the job but you're really just
focusing on the versions of those
applications and letting App Engine
scale that application for you and then
finally this is this is really exciting
is just cloud functions where you can
literally go in and there's some other
great sessions where you see how short
the code is but just go into the UI
enter the code you know could be several
lines that responds to an event this
event could be a new blob is put in your
GCS bucket I want to do something with
send it somewhere maybe do a little bit
of processing zip it up that could be a
very simple short and sweet cloud
function where you don't need to worry
about where that cloud function runs how
to provision it how to set up the
networking in the in the environment
just give us the function and we'll run
it for you to automatically scale it and
only charge you for the resources it
used and so that's the important part
which is as you move through the
spectrum we're very keen on making sure
you pay only for what you use and of
course what you used varies based on how
managed you want that infrastructure to
be so in the kubernetes world you're
paying for the cluster those are the VMS
that the cluster is running on in the
App Engine world is paying for the
instances that App Engine is spinning up
for you that's running the backend
in front-end applications and then cloud
functions it's really just the
management feed the indications of the
function and the actual compute cycles
run by the cloud function great so on
this slide what I what I want to capture
is just what I've talked about which is
these different levels of management
that you can choose from and so if you
are choosing kubernetes engine you're
still saying what you'd really value the
control over some of the cluster
management over the application
deployment over setting that up but if
you don't value that controller that's
just not worth it to you you can go
through the spectrum and get to
something like cloud functions we're
just focused on writing the code and pay
only for what you use and there's no
right answer you may be using multiple
these technologies within your
organization because some teams value
one and other teams value the other so
I'm gonna hand it back to Devo will talk
to you about cloud storage and then I'll
come back to talk to you that managed
service platform thank you very much
Stephen appreciate that so storage we've
talked a little bit about compute and
storage is the very obvious analog for
resources that you want to make sure you
keep track of when it comes to your
business and your value now we talked a
little bit before about all the costs
involved with running your compute
processes and workloads on Prem and you
have to think very similarly when you're
thinking about your storage workloads I
won't go through all the different
elements that we discussed before but
I've call your attention very
specifically to the idea that you have
to think about unavailability as a cost
when you think about not being able to
serve either internally or externally
the different types of data that you
have to process for people that has a
cost to your business and you want to
make sure that you're aware of that as
well and you have to think about
repairability and other elements like
that on-premises as well moving forward
you also have to think about the value
questions that you drive when you're
making decisions with regards to storage
on GCP for example can you handle
multiple or single disk failures how do
you optimize for different types of
storage use cases how do you instantly
access the different types of stores
that may hold the data that's very
to you and let's say that you want to go
more granular let's say I want to focus
on data certain structures and buckets
or rows and databases or in no sequel
databases and so on how can I take
advantage of all that from a storage
perspective so that brings us of course
to Google Cloud storage and then the
nutshell it's very simple and elegant
just focus on creating your storage
buckets put the data that you need into
them and of course make sure that you
control your access as necessary
from a public internal or private
perspective and then once you're done
remove that data and/or roaming with the
bucket now I want to take a minute to
make sure that you guys understand the
different classes of storage we offer
because that's one of the great values
that we can provide and one of the great
ways you can extract more value one
thing about your storage when you think
about multi-regional storage that's the
most frequently accessed data that
you're going to have in your set
more or less it's gonna need to be
accessed globally and you want to have
low end user latency and so it's
fantastic for those global data sets
then of course you might move into more
durable and more localized storage with
regional let's say you need to do some
analytics processing or you need to look
at some video encoding for a specific
business or internal purposes that's
more of your regional data set or use
case then we move into more of the less
frequently accessed storage or data use
cases with near line and cold line near
line is for data you typically want to
access once a month or less so we're
thinking about redundancy or backup use
cases and then of course cold line is
more of an archival use case so you want
to make sure you think about your data
storage and some of those different
types of classes now I've told you just
as I did with compute that I have
different ways for you to take advantage
of the different things we provide in
Google Cloud Storage so once again I'll
divide them up into different types of
behaviors and different types of tools
you can use on the behavior side you
definitely want to make sure that
you choose the right storage class you
want to make sure that if you need to
have high frequency data like websites
or things like that streaming media that
you need other people to access you want
to focus more on the multi-regional
section of the use cases but if you got
our chi ville stuff focus on putting it
in cold line as soon as you can you want
to make sure that you properly tune your
access the last thing you want as a
customer as to think about someone who
you don't want access in your data going
into your storage buckets and gaining
access definitely make sure you do that
because that of course increases the
frequency with what you need to serve
that data and might move it across
classes as well then the last thing I'd
tell you to do is turn on object
lifecycle management object lifecycle
management is particularly useful
because you can move your data across
the storage classes I just introduced to
you by creating policies that will do it
automatically so in some cases if you're
realizing that some of your documents
have a life cycle and they're frequently
accesses first but the less and less
relevant they get the less and less they
get accessed you can set specific
policies to move those things
automatically from save multi-regional
or regional to Col vine or Nearline on
the tool side of the house you want to
focus on using a single API for all of
those storage classes that's
particularly useful because you don't
have to change any of your code to
access the storage buckets that you're
creating depending on what class they
live in then we also have two things to
help you move your data around we have a
cloud transfer appliance and we have a
cloud transfer service the appliance is
particularly useful and helping you move
your data from on-prem into GCS the
cloud transfer service is for moving it
from one cloud to another so both of
those are particularly helpful I
encourage you to take full advantage of
both of those and finally there's a
storage growth plan to help you take
care of the volatility that comes from
dealing with storage costs I'll give you
a few more comments on that more
specifically the idea behind the storage
growth plan is to help you think about
how I'm gonna deal with the fact that
storage costs may increase or decrease
fairly unpredictably so what we allow
you to do is if you're able to commit to
$10,000 or spend over 12 months then you
can grow your store data as you need to
that volatility will just happen and you
don't have to worry about overage during
that time at the end of that commit
period you can either do one of several
options the first saying hey at my peak
usage I'm gonna focus on how much that
costs and deal with the overages now and
renew or I'm gonna keep my plan the same
settle up on all the overages I incur
Dover the past year because I was able
to think about and monitor and predict
over that period of time and do this
according to growth storage plan terms
particularly useful when you have a lot
of storage and a lot of meaty yet to
take care of but you have no idea at
first what it's gonna cost so we've
talked about the value of Google Cloud
Storage let's talk again about the total
costs one of the things I'd imagine
you'd really want to take advantage of
if you especially if you're just
starting out with Google Cloud storage
is to take advantage of the always free
tier that is we give you a very fixed
amount of regional storage a whole bunch
of operations that you can use in terms
of moving your data around as necessary
and network egress that's always free
just so you can get an idea of how you
want to move those workloads around the
other thing to think about is that costs
decrease by access so you can look at
the prices per gigabyte month and see
that multi-regional storage might be
three-tenths of a cent per gigabyte
month but as you move down the storage
class spectrum you'll find that cold
line storage is for hundredths of a cent
so if you optimize your workloads for
that kind of storage cost you can save a
lot of money then of course is the third
thing you need to think about which is
the fact that you can pay as you go or
use a storage growth plan we're giving
you two options based on how much you
might know and how predictable your
workloads are now you guys might be
saying diba this is great this is super
awesome we've got Google Cloud storage
but I
have to store things at Wigmore granular
levels than that what are my choices I
don't want to overwhelm you guys but we
have quite a few in fact when you want
to think about all the different choices
you have there's very very ranging
possibilities from thinking about
relational databases or no sequel and
in-memory databases block and file
storage and of course the
general-purpose storage we were just
talking about with Google Cloud storage
the main thing I want you to think about
here is that it's also a spectrum very
similar to what Stephen presented to you
with compute in some cases the main
value of using some of these services
that we manage some of the boilerplate
work that you have to do for you in
exchange for it increased costs in some
senses or a simple cost in a simple
management structure and others and
bigquery is included in there as one of
our great best-in-class analysis tools
that Stephens going to talk to you about
just a moment in any case take advantage
of all the different tools and behaviors
you can use with Google Cloud storage in
order to get the most from your dollar
in that sense now I'm going to hand it
over to Stephen to talk a little bit
more about the server list platform and
the analysis you can do with bigquery
be loud and clear from the managed
compute section that we just talked
about so bigquery helps you just write
queries don't worry about provisioning
the database the storage the compute
just analyze your data cloud pub/sub
lets you just send messages send the
data where it needs to go and then
something like cloud dataflow is a
serverless
processing pipeline so just process the
data don't worry about how to provision
that Hadoop cluster for example so
bigquery is a product I really love is
it not just me being biased my wife is a
user experience research on bigquery so
this is not just me transitively loving
bigquery but it's a really cool product
and what I love about this diagram is it
shares the scale of it so it's based on
Dremel Google technology that we use to
power our internal analyses and it's
completely separated the federated
storage of the data that it's analyzing
and the analysis of that data and what's
especially cool here is a distributed
memory shuffle tier so basically what
that is it's a it's a way for compute to
be completely stateless and analyze a
lot of federated data shuffling the
memory so that if any of the nodes go
down there's no problem the analysis
doesn't fail if any of the stores goes
down so no it's no problem it's highly
durable its replicated so we have
exabytes scale storage on the left and
we've got petabyte you know within
minutes scale analysis on the right and
if you just think about that for a
moment I used to work at another company
before I came to cloud and would be
Monday night there's a Wednesday metrics
meeting that was very famous in the
company and I would hit contention with
every other product manager trying to do
analysis on our data warehouse because
we didn't have a million core cluster
that could scale a thousand compute
cores for my analysis and I was always
running against two other people on kind
of node based data warehouse systems so
this is really really I really love this
product and what you can use that with
is you can use it as kind of an
intermediate stop for where your data's
going so you might be using cloud
pub/sub in your service data platform to
send messages maybe from your
internet-of-things endpoints stand up a
dataflow pipeline so that you can
process all that data
going into bigquery and then maybe
couple that with cloud machine learning
so that you can train on the data
develop models that are reliable and
give you the right insights from the
data and then run those very same models
in cloud ml to do prediction on the
streaming data so again what we really
want to focus on here is drive value
from only the pieces that you want to
work on so just write the queries just
send the data just create the pipeline's
you know just develop the models for
machine learning and then only pay for
what you use so in the case of bigquery
what you use is there's a charge for
streaming ingestion no charge for batch
loading and then there's a charge for
the storage of the data and for the
analysis of that data and actually the
analysis comes in two flavors on-demand
which is just as fast as what we see
inside of Google is something that
discharged you for any on-demand storage
based on data scanned but if you have
large bigquery needs you can also opt
for a flat rate model where you ask us
to reserve bigquery slots for you and
those are dedicated slots that can be
saved just for your jobs and also give
you cost predictability over time so
that's something to consider in the case
of cloud pub/sub just pay for the data
that you sent in cloud pub/sub dataflow
is the data process plus the workers
working on that data and then cloud
machine learning is just paying for the
resources required to train your model
and to apply it to data to create
predictions so end to end what's really
beautiful about a serverless data
platform you just focus on the through
line where does the data come from where
you want it to go and what
transformations you want to have to have
what transformations you want to apply
to it on its way to say your data
analyst or your scientist or your or
your business manager in in the
visualization dashboard so we have
plenty of cases internally where we
actually do very similar things comes
into bigquery as a product manager I do
actually analysis of my own products in
bigquery and then power a data studio
dashboard with it so I can see what's
going on with my products and it's all
very very easy because I don't need to
worry about the resources so we've we've
done a lot of talking about total value
how to think about total value of
moving to a more cloud native way of
doing things and the cost that come with
deriving that value so I want to spend a
little bit of time and there's deeper
sessions later and next but I want to
spend a little bit of time talking about
cost management tools so one thing we've
learned just talking to many different
customers of different sizes is that
regardless of the size of the customer
there's some common needs for cost
management and these are kind of
captured here there's the need to see to
visualize what your costs are in a way
that's meaningful to you and then to
hold the right people accountable so if
if it's me or a Deebo that's
overspending on the bigquery queries
finalizing my products that's something
that we can analyze and we can see where
the costs are going if we need to do
anything differently
same thing for compute and any other
other products and then of course if you
can hold people accountable you might
also want to be able to just have
control for peace of mind and confidence
that you can run your workloads in the
cloud with predictable costs and with
the right level of control and then
finally you expect to get some kind of
insights or intelligent recommendations
about how to optimize your workloads and
again this is true regardless of what
size of customer you are and there's
something that you should do before you
get to this phase and this is there's a
whole talk on this that a colleague
James Byers will give on this but the
way we like to think about cost
management is we want to make sure that
you can manage your cost the way you
organize your work and this is you know
to a large extent is an offline kind of
discussion with your teammates with your
colleagues about how do we organize our
work how do we organize the value we're
delivering as a company do we organize
it by cost center do we organize it by
apps front end versus back in and again
there's no right answer and sometimes a
hybrid model of organizing work and
value is important but once you have a
sense of how you like to track the value
you're delivering then we offer tools to
help you organize your cloud environment
that way so there's the organization
that could just be your domain name my
company comm folders that might
represent teams applications or cost
centers those are ways to organize the
projects and if you're familiar with
Google cloud project is kind of the
fundamental unit of
of an environment where all resources
within a project you can see the cost
for all resources in a project and the
use of trail recent project and you can
also control access and policies via
this hierarchy and then finally there
are labels so there may be things you
want to be able to track across your
organization for example security
workloads R&D workloads other overhead
workloads that might not belong to any
single branch in hierarchy and so labels
are something else to consider using and
the reason you want to do this is to be
able to answer some of these evergreen
questions so talk about visibility
accountability control and intelligence
the questions behind those are kind of
fundamental and they tend not to vary
that much so what are the value and
costs of my applications what direction
are those trending do I understand the
drivers of those trends and then finally
what what might I do to optimize so
optimization might not simply be about
reducing cost but just making sure that
there's again sub linear scaling that
you know growth in costs if there's much
higher growth in revenue is absolutely
fine but growth in cost that might be
greater than growth in revenue is
something to keep an eye out for and at
any level of the organization whether
it's the CIO the business owner the
engineering manager the developer these
tend to be the same questions we always
get support calls about and we get into
discussions with customers about it's
just different zoom ins on the fractal
of cost management and we provide tools
to help provide any level of visibility
that you might need so here's just a
summary of the tools and there's again
another in-depth session on cost
management that'll go into these more
deeply but we provide out-of-the-box
cost reports that you can slice and dice
your cost any way you want within the
Google cloud console if you want more
deep more detailed view of cost for
example you really want to get into the
labeling and you really want to see
things like kind of an hour to two hour
granularity there's detailed billing
export which sends all of your cost data
into bigquery because that's the best
place we think you know we can send it
for analysis and then for control
there's budgets alerts and quotas so one
thing to keep in mind there is budgets
and alerts are kind of a lagging
indicator what you spend is a little bit
of a lagging indicator
for cost-control quota on the other hand
is quotas set on usage by you know user
by certain sets of permissions and
that's that's proactive that gets in
front of the spending but you depend on
the application whether it's production
testing you can imagine that some usage
of quota is more appropriate than others
and some usage of budget some alerts are
more appropriate than others and then
finally their recommendations so
different products have their
recommendations about how to optimize
one that debo talked about was VM right
sizing recommendations and there are
other recommendations like that that we
can provide insight into how you use
your committee use discounts for example
and those just help you figure out if
there are opportunities to optimize your
spending or just reconfigure the way
you're doing things to get the most out
of Google Cloud so to recap I'll kind of
bring you back to how debo introduced
the session and we talked about
comparing value to cost and in
particular just trying to see the
thought that the usual way of looking at
this is a little bit inadequate and the
insidious thing about this is this the
way everyone I always think about things
is just how does the cost change not it
so it's always harder to think about how
the value changes or how the culture of
your team changes or how the way you
build things and maintain the changes
but if we can move from this model of
thinking about costs and value to a
model that really thinks about what you
get from moving to very flexible compute
platform a highly kind of diversified
and tailorable storage platform managed
compute services a service data platform
and many other products that we offer an
API that we offer then what I think is
the most exciting part of this
discussion is how the value trend
changes and the just kind of the gap
that it opens between what you're able
to deliver to your own customers and
what costs you're able to reduce on the
back end so to tie it up this is why we
call ourselves Google cloud platform and
we think the more the more and more we
can be the platform that you're building
value on the more you can focus on
building what's next for your business
and that's that's why Devo and I are at
Google cloud it's a really exciting
people always ask us why
we billing product managers and it's
because this is actually a really
exciting part about our job and we
really look forward to working with you
as you do that so before we break I
mentioned some other deep dive sessions
colleague of ours Manish dal wadi is
great giving an intermediate talk on how
to save money with compute engine and
how to get value out of compute engine
highly recommend that talk we have
another colleague nat leonard he's doing
a panel with several industry leaders
one from etsy a specialist leader from
Deloitte and a couple others on cost
control and financial governance and
that'll be a good one for you to get a
sense of the different methods of having
good financial governance and cost
control depending on your organizational
needs and then on Wednesday I'm giving a
talk with that Deutsch specialist leader
on actually using the monitoring and
cost control tools that we offer as the
cost management team so we look forward
to seeing you there and then finally
another session that I'd like to
recommend is one run by our colleague
Phil Coletti that's filled with two L's
and that's establishing financial
governance controls on GCP and he's
giving that with orally phone Tony who's
a product manager on quota and then
we'll be at the cost management showcase
all week there's a nasty expert booth
where you can schedule time with one of
the Google cloud staffers who are here
and then finally if there's one URL you
want to write down it's cloud google.com
slash cost management and we'll be
posting all the talks on cost management
there and other resources there so
that's a great kind of hub for cost
management resources
[Music]